digamos que dirigimos una escuela ya
tenemos una población de estudiantes
aquí y queremos darnos una idea de cómo
estos estudiantes se sienten con
respecto a la calidad de las clases de
matemáticas aquí realizamos una encuesta
y necesitamos decidir quiénes van a
responder dicha encuesta
una opción es encuesta a cada uno de los
miembros de esta población pero digamos
que es una población muy grande
imaginemos que es una universidad con
miles de estudiantes quizás con 10.000
estudiantes y no podemos hablar con cada
uno de ellos así que en su lugar
decidimos tomar una muestra de esta
población para darnos una idea de cómo
se siente toda la escuela así que vamos
a tomar una muestra de esta población y
para evitar tener sesgo en las
respuestas o tener la mayor oportunidad
de obtener el mejor indicador de esta
población queremos que nuestra muestra
sea aleatoria así que nuestra muestra
puede ser aleatoria o no aleatoria y el
principio podría verse muy evidente que
debemos hacer una muestra aleatoria pero
a veces no es tan fácil tener una
muestra aleatoria un tipo de muestra
aleatoria es la muestra aleatoria simple
y esto podría ser no sé digamos que
asignamos un número diferente a cada uno
de los estudiantes de esta población
quizá podríamos usar su número de
matrícula o su número de identificación
y usamos una computadora para tener un
generador de números aleatorios que nos
genere 100 números aleatorios que
corresponderán a los 100 estudiantes que
serán nuestra muestra y a quienes les
aplicaremos la encuesta esta sería una
muestra aleatoria simple vamos a
dibujarlo aquí ésta es nuestra población
y aleatoriamente estamos eligiendo
personas de aquí y sabemos que es
aleatoria porque estos números están
siendo generados por un generador de
números aleatorios quizá tenemos una
cadena de números que nos permite elegir
a los estudiantes y esto está muy bien
es poco probable que tengamos sesgo en
esta muestra pero hay cierta
probabilidad de que un generador de
números aleatorios puedan elegir una
cantidad desproporcionada de hombre
con respecto a mujeres o una cantidad
desproporcionada de alumnos de nuevo
ingreso con respecto a alumnos de último
año o quizá una cantidad
desproporcionada de estudiantes de
ingeniería con respecto a estudiantes de
idiomas esa es una posibilidad así que
aunque estemos tomando una muestra
aleatoria simple aunque sea realmente
aleatoria nuevamente quizá haya alguna
probabilidad de que no se tenga un
indicador de toda la población así que
para mitigar esto existen otras técnicas
que podemos aplicar una técnica es el
muestreo estratificado esta es la idea
de tomar toda nuestra población y
esencialmente estratificar la por
conveniencia la vamos a dibujar como un
rectángulo aquí y digamos que la vamos a
estratificar para tener una muestra
equilibrada de estudiantes de primer año
segundo año tercer año y cuarto año así
lo hacemos aquí va en primer año segundo
año tercer año y cuarto año y vamos a
muestrear a 25 de cada uno de estos
grupos
esta es la estratificación
en lugar de muestrear 100 de toda la
población muestre amos a 25 de cada uno
de estos grupos y con esto nos
aseguramos de tener indicadores o
respuestas de al menos cada uno de estos
grupos aunque quizá haya otro problema
ustedes pueden decir bueno nos preocupa
tener la representación adecuada de
hombres y de mujeres y quizá haya cierta
probabilidad de que si yo hago una
muestra aleatoria siempre de 100
personas aquí tenga una proporción de 50
y 50 pero debido a lo aleatorio de esto
hay cierta probabilidad de que no sea
así que tengamos una mayor proporción de
hombres que de mujeres o viceversa y
esto también puede ocurrir aquí así que
pueden aplicar una técnica que se llama
muestreo por conglomerados
y lo que hacemos es muestrear grupos y
cada uno de esos grupos tenemos
confianza de que tiene una proporción
balanceada de hombres y de mujeres así
que en lugar de muestrear individuos de
la población completa
podríamos decir aunque esto no es algo
trivial de hacer pero digamos que
podemos dividir a nuestra población en
grupos podríamos imaginar que son
salones de clase y en cada uno de estos
salones tenemos una distribución pareja
de hombres y mujeres o algo muy cercano
a ello así que lo que hacemos es
muestrear los salones y es por eso que
se le llama por conglomerados ya que
vamos a muestrear aleatoriamente en
nuestros salones y cada uno de ellos
tiene una cantidad equilibrada de
hombres y mujeres así que vamos a tener
una buena representación pero seguimos
haciendo un muestreo muestre amos los
conglomerados vamos a encuestar a cada
una de las personas de estos
conglomerados que elijamos nuevamente
todas estas son formas de obtener
muestras aleatorias tenemos la muestra
aleatoria simple tenemos el muestreo
y el muestreo por conglomerados y vamos
a encuestar a cada una de las personas
de los grupos seleccionados todas estas
son muestras aleatorias pero que hay de
las muestras no aleatorias pues un caso
no aleatorio es cuando tenemos muestreos
de respuesta voluntaria esto sería el
caso si le dijéramos a todos los
estudiantes de la escuela que tenemos
una página web y que se les invita a
participar en una encuesta ahí aquí es
muy probable que haya sesgo ya que
quizás sólo aquellos estudiantes que de
verdad les guste la clase de matemáticas
participen en la encuesta porque quizás
es probable que la mayoría de los
estudiantes que realmente les gusta la
instrucción de matemáticas en la escuela
o quizás sólo participen aquellos
estudiantes que no les gustan las clases
de matemáticas en la escuela o quizá
participen solo aquellos estudiantes que
tienen más tiempo para ello así que aquí
hay una gran probabilidad de tener sesgo
ya que los estudiantes que participen
voluntariamente en esta encuesta quizá
tengan más inclinación hacia una opinión
que otra otra muestra no haya
o bien es el que llamamos muestreo por
conveniencia introducimos sesgo por
conveniencia
a lo mejor decimos bueno vamos a
encuestar a los primeros 100 estudiantes
que se presenten en la escuela que es
algo muy conveniente ya que no tenemos
que elegir estos números aleatorios o
hacer la estratificación o los
conglomerados pero pueden darse cuenta
que eso también nos va a dar un sesgo ya
que quizás los primeros 100 estudiantes
que lleguen a la escuela son aquellos
que son más diligentes o quizás tienen
muy buenos maestros de matemáticas o les
gusta mucho la materia o al contrario
pueden tener instructores que no les
gusten para nada y quizá se introduzca
sesgo hacia el otro lado
así que si dejamos que las personas
participen voluntariamente o los
elegimos por conveniencia como por
ejemplo los primeros 100 estudiantes que
pasen por enfrente de mí o los primeros
100 estudiantes que encuentren en este
momento pues podría ser algo conveniente
pero no serán una muestra verdaderamente
aleatoria y hay otras razones por las
que podemos tener sesgo y que no sea
debido a la muestra una de ellas puede
ser debida a la red
de la pregunta en la encuesta quizá la
pregunta diga te sientes afortunado de
poder tener acceso a clases de
matemáticas pues aquí quizá nos veamos
tentados a responder siempre que sí o
quizás si la redacción de la pregunta
fuera algo así como estás satisfecho de
que un mayor porcentaje de los
estudiantes de esta escuela reprueba
álgebra comparado con las escuelas
vecinas pues quizá esto nos dé el sesgo
de responder negativamente por lo que la
redacción de cada pregunta realmente
importa en las encuestas y otra forma de
tener sesgo es el sesgo de respuesta y
este no es debido a la muestra esto
simplemente se debe a que quizás algunas
personas no quieran responder
honestamente a la encuesta o quizá no
quieran responder nada quizá temen que
de cierta manera sus respuestas se den a
conocer en frente de los maestros de
matemáticas y quizá ellos tomen
represalias por eso y por eso quizás no
quieran responder honestamente a las
preguntas de la encuesta este
un repaso muy general sobre cómo podemos
diseñar nuestras muestras buscamos que
sean aleatorias porque disminuye la
probabilidad de tener sesgo y estas son
algunas técnicas para diseñar las y
también vimos cómo podemos caer en estos
errores que nos incrementan la
posibilidad de tener sesgo en nuestros
resultados